oui et bien menée par un autochtone si
c'est melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine encore une fois grâce à mère
nature je peux faire ma chronique à
l'extérieur profiter du beau temps et
comme elle est généreuse profite aussi
du temps de me faire piquer par un
maringouin et ça me dérange même pas
puisque pendant des mois on a été
confiné on été gardés à la maison on
sait garder en distanciation sociale et
on continue de le faire
cependant bénéficié des lieux de nature
c'est vraiment ce qui est de plus sa
guirlande de toutes ces semaines à
l'intérieur de la maison
bien sûr ça fait vraiment ressortir le
niveau de confiance que l'on a eu à voir
notre gouvernement dès le début du conte
vide
d'ailleurs les peler les statistiques
ont jamais été aussi favorable envers un
gouvernement dès le début de la crise du
coc vide
cependant cette semaine j'ai vu aussi
qu'on peut faire des abus ce niveau de
confiance quand on pense par exemple à
sonia savage qui a fait une déclaration
lors d'un podcast où elle dit eh bien il
n'y a jamais eu un meilleur moment pour
faire passer les pipelines puisque les
gens ne peuvent pas se réunir plus que
15 à la fois donc fait les passez vos
pipeline et sa salle a fait ressortir
une problématique énorme
et là je pense je pense pas partir dans
une grande envolée conspirationnistes
mais je parle par exemple des abus de
confiance
quand une population complète s'engagent
à se garder à distance à se garder en
sécurité et que sur le côté le
gouvernement continue de faire des
démarches qui elles sont pas nécessaires
sont pas des services essentiels
mais son corps seront traités comme tels
pour pouvoir favoriser des écoliers ou
des industries alors l'alberta bien sûr
mais aussi la saskatchewan et le
manitoba ou des communautés autochtones
ont bloqué les routes pour pouvoir
empêcher l'accès de travailleurs dans
des territoires autochtones pour qu'ils
aient accès justement l hydroélectricité
ou au miel et même au québec
là je pense aux caribous de val d'or où
démotive riez on annonçait justement
qu'on allait mettre les derniers membres
de la horde de val-d'or en enclos et on
se rappelle qu'en 2007
ça va être un grand tollé quand on avait
annoncé qu'on mettrait les caribous de
val d'or aux outre saint félicien là on
décide de les mettre dans un enclos à 15
kilomètres de val d'or
cependant le déplacement de ces hordes
se sont fait au moins de mars
ici vous vous rappelez bien aux menaces
on était en plein début du confinement
on était justement moi comme des
centaines de militants et aussi de
citoyens en train de repenser notre mode
de vie fut notre manière de faire
comment allons-nous travailler quand nos
enfants sont à la maison
est-ce qu'on va avoir encore des emplois
alors pendant que nous étions préoccupés
par des centaines de questions de
personnel
et bien ce déplacement a été fait et
bien sûr a été fait sans aucune
manifestation sans aucune opposition
puisque le co vu de l'exigence et bien
on n'a pas pu se présenter est en des
places publiques pour pouvoir s'y
opposer donc vous pouvez imaginer qu'on
regardera sûrement jamais ce taux de
confiance là même quand la deuxième
vague du coc vide va frapper
cependant ça donne beaucoup à réfléchir
par rapport à ce que le gouvernement
pourrait faire pour arrêter de perdre se
dit confiant cela alors ce qui est bon
pour nous devrait donc pour vous aussi
et les communautés autochtones
présentement sont les plus à risque
puisque les politiques de confinement
sont gardés en place puisqu'on est une
population qui est beaucoup plus de
risques de santé liés aux villes mais on
voit aussi une opposition très farouche
par rapport à nos politiques de
confinement
quand ça veut dire vous n'excéderait pas
nos territoires vous ne peut pas aller à
ces endroits le plus que nous y sommes
et nous ne voulons pas prendre de risque
pour notre santé donc est-ce qu'on va
revivre ce genre de confiance envers
notre gouvernement
historiquement je pourrais dire que les
premières nations ont toujours une leçon
ici des histoires sur ma ne pas faire
confiance au gouvernement
mais par exemple la population elle
devrait pouvoir se lier entre elles pour
justement éviter que ce genre d'abus la
arrive dans le futur alors je me demande
si vous aussi vous avez malheureusement
vécu ce petit air de confiance là est-ce
que vous avez encore envie de donner
cette auto de confiance à votre
gouvernement
donc n'hésitez pas à nous mais des
questions dans les commentaires
n'hésitez pas à partager ses vidéos je
souhaite une belle semaine